this presentation is delivered by the
Stanford center for professional
development
and now let's get started today I'm
joined by two of my esteemed colleagues
data doctor dr. Dave beach and Kurt
biter of the Stanford School of
Engineering they reach is a professor of
mechanical engineering and director of
the product realization laboratory at
Stanford University which provides 950
students annually with hands-on
experience and product definition
conceptual design detail design and
prototype creation the laboratory offers
courses coaches mentors and tools and
support of integrated product creation
it has engendered many companies which
design manufacture and distribute
products and divers domains including
alternative energy system automated
genomics laboratory equipment haptic
devices medical devices sporting goods
transportation products and underwater
imaging equipment professor beaches goal
is to provide a student's strengths and
tacit knowledge which derives from the
hands-on synthesis of design prototype
building presentation and criticism the
resulting judgement and instinct
regarding materials devices materials
transformation process and design
process complements classical analytical
engineering education to create create
superior engineers her advisor is that
acting associate professor of mechanical
engineering and director of modeling
manufacturing modeling lab here at
Stanford University he has been an
integral part of the design for
manufacturing research and teaching team
addressing the key issues of competitive
product development the design
manufacturing course sequence was
developed to meet the needs of
world-class organizations and over the
years its faculty has partnered with
many companies such as applied materials
Cisco harley-davidson and Toshiba dr.
biters research interests focus on
design for manufacturing design for
robustness life cycle design
probabilistic design system reliability
and product innovation gentlemen thank
you for being with us today
slava thank you very much for that
generous introduction Kurt and I are
here this morning to discuss a pair of
courses this is an experiment for us we
haven't tried this duet before and I'm
really looking forward to it a curt is
going to talk to you about design for
manufacturability me3 17 a and B right
and I'm going to talk to you about good
products bad products it's a single
quarter course me3 14 let me lead off
good products bad products takes as its
bumper sticker if you can measure it
we're not interested in it that's
contrary to the usual view of quality
which is a very detailed very intensive
very energetic very creative adventure
in reducing variability we understand
very well in good products bad products
that until you have reduced variability
in your manufacturing process there's
not much point in talking about all the
things that go on in me3 14 what does go
on in me3 14 is an attempt to help
engineers understand the human values
associated with successful designs
topics such as human fifth craftsmanship
needs and emotions elegance and
sophistication cultural values symbolism
and global constraints and this slide is
intended to be an iconic image for needs
and emotion how about joy of flying in
order to enjoy flying most human beings
need to do something different than jump
off the garage roof and flap their arms
so we as a species have invented kites
balloons dirigibles blimps airplanes
rocket ship space shuttles and all kinds
of other ways to become airborne
trampolines noteworthy among them
interest particularly from a value point
of view this is the icon a5 it's an
aircraft which is responding to a new
category promulgated by the federal
aviation Association about five years
ago and its purpose is an unmitigated
try being a toy for effluent people who
want extreme adventures so if you are
jumping out of airplanes cry
senior ski-doo into pine trees if you
are driving motorcycles at 150 miles an
hour going around corners at the same
time you are a candidate to buy an icon
a5 it is a brilliant piece of industrial
design it pays attention to many of the
things that go on in good products bad
products and in fact it's the product of
two of our graduate students these are
the categories of topics which we
discuss so how do you discuss them there
are no partial differential equations
there is no matrix algebra in this
course we actually use images video
clips and spoken and written words so
the chapters in the principal reading
for this course the principal reading is
a book by Jim Adams which is called
amazingly enough good products bad
products some thoughts by Jim Adams are
human fit and there's cognitive issues
there and there's economic issues there
and there's additional issues their
craftsmanship joy to the maker joy to
the user needs and emotions do you love
it you hate it which is better probably
than blah which is a third option
aesthetics elegance and sophistication
wisdom through experience you develop an
aesthetic sense probably not born with
it through your early experience and
your and your sophistication level is
certainly born of experience cultural
values and symbolism where do you come
from who are you and global constraints
can we sustainably remain on this planet
and behave in in whatever way the design
manufacture use and retirement of the
product actually represent I'm Dave
beach you can reach me with the
following contact information and
sometimes you'll find you need to try
more than once I am notoriously
inattentive to email and since you're
probably not on campus ambushing me
during my office hours probably won't
work either so the real secret is to
call my administrative assistant or send
electronic mail to her her phone number
is 650 723 for 287 and her email address
is je NRA hm that's je & R Ahn at
stanford.edu
I think it's only fair that you should
have some sense for the personality of
the instructor when you sign up for a
course we have a thing called course
shopping here at Stanford and so I feel
a responsibility to explain Who I am and
who my TA is on the very first day of
class that's my iconic picture of me I
love my 1950 GMC pickup truck if you
happen to be working for General Motors
you deserve a lot of congratulations
this machine drives every day whenever I
ask it to it carries heavy loads and so
far it hasn't filled me through that
special design feature of the steering
column starts just behind the front
bumper and stops just short of my heart
cavity this is Jim Adams he's the author
of the principal reading in this course
it was his course originally and when it
retired I was distressed that it might
go away because all other quality
courses are about mathematics and this
one was actually about qualitative
issues in quality and since I figured it
was pretty unique I made a deal with
joey said Jim come out of retirement for
one quarter Wilco teach the course if it
goes well I'll try and take it over and
that was eight years ago and now I've
gotten to the point where I don't want
Jim to come into the classroom because
I've made it my own and I just want to
have my own way in every detail this is
a course that involves a lot of
discussion that also in court involves
writing papers making videos doing field
research there are many creative
opportunities in this course the field
research is driven by concepts that come
from qualitative marketing and we're
very lucky to have somebody named Bonnie
one who runs a qualitative marketing
consultancy to launch the course
originally and she encourages getting
into people's homes maybe into their
showers maybe in a ver garages to really
understand who they are she likes to ask
questions like what's your favorite
music I won't mention all of the
questions she like to ask in order to
develop a real sense for the customer we
also care a lot about the making of
things this is an image of tableware
made in Sausalito California I happen to
be a strong proponent of local
manufacturing that is domestic
manufacturing and we care a lot about
design and I will claim that this image
helps you understand what we mean by
elegance and sophistication and design
made by a combination of machines and
artisans many of the products have come
out of the product realization lab and
that are exemplary in this course have
to do with sports not necessarily the
kind of sports that you might kill
yourself doing like jumping out of
airplanes but sports that develop real
athleticism Peter Grasso gawker founded
a company called concept to he now owns
a lake in morrisville Vermont and he is
the pioneer for carbon fiber epoxy
rowing equipment he's also been very
smart about creating community and one
of the things that makes a product
successful is if surrounding that
product is a story and community well it
turns out anybody who rose gets up at
five in the morning works really hard
knows how to experience pain and
consequently it's a preformed community
you can go almost anywhere in the world
and if you roll you could send a letter
ahead a couple of weeks and they would
invite you to come on their Sunday row
and they'd have a banquet for you when
you get back to shore the other
manifestation of this is competitions
with concept 200 meters are held all
over the world stats are kept records
are distributed awards are made so
developing communities and important
part of marketing that's the concept 200
meter it succeeds because it feels like
rowing so it has to do with what does it
feel like and that has something to do
with human fit also that's something to
do with aesthetics margarito was the
first rig platinum-certified
environmental home LEED Platinum
certified environmental home in Northern
California this is a form of design that
relates to global constraints how can we
live well and still be responsible
towards the environment there's a food
module and good products bad products
food is moderately important where it's
grown how it's grown what the business
models might be are one of the modules
that we will address in the global
constraints section we also believe in
designing for the bottom of the pyramid
most of the people on the world live on
one to two dollars a day they're small
plus subsistence farmers and products
appropriate for them or a wonderful
opportunity to look at designing
quality thanks day for what i think is
look to be a very interesting course i
should look in to see him perhaps if i
could enroll in that class but you know
it's one of the i don't know truisms any
place that you know we all work in our
own silos and it's not invented here you
know it doesn't exist but dave and i
actually doing this webinar together we
had an opportunity to kind of you know
revisit what each of us do in the class
and he mentioned something that
hopefully will get a chance to come back
to if you can measure it we're not
interested in it and let me just jump
into the next slide 12 I 210b 317 design
methods which you know the word design
certainly is something that will be
covered in both of our classes and David
mentioned this airplane up near the
front of this talk a product that's
getting close to production the go ahead
and hit the build slide thanks so a lot
can happen on the way to the market
surveys class is all about if you will
identifying an opportunity or perhaps
some challenges in your existing design
well unfortunately well fortunately
there perhaps many opportunities when
we're in the product development stages
of improving the overall product whether
it be delight cost you know
manufacturing capability and so forth
but there's also many ways that your
product can fail on the way to market so
for instance for this particular
airplane there might be a great aha this
underserved market that's the folks that
are driving ski-doos or power boats or
expensive motorcycles the extreme
thrilled sports lovers do you really
understand that those market
requirements in terms of you know the
aesthetics versus the performance versus
how much it costs what is your target
costs for a product such as this
the technology that goes in you can see
that this airplane has a new or perhaps
unconventional architecture when we're
talking about general aviation now I
know the ultralight sports airplane
market is anything but conventional in
terms of architecture but does this
concept is it actually going to deliver
in terms of the cost reliability you
know even he mentioned the FAA they
provide requirements as well that it's
not fully understood before you start
cutting tooling to actually make this
plane can certainly have a big big
impact on the relative success of the
business model so let's go to the next
slide so me3 17 then is a systematic
design course which essentially provides
a toolbox for addressing all of these
varied product requirements whether it
be something coming from the
stakeholders some sort of manufacturing
challenge or opportunity the business
model and so forth so we have many tools
in our toolbox 317 is a experience based
project based course that will show you
using hands on a hands-on real project
how to come up with a project definition
with the right feature set the right
cost with the correct time to market
next slide if you look at the content of
the tool we address all phases of
product development I mentioned we are a
project-based course any projects that
you would come into the class with could
be at various stages of maturity so it
could be you're still in the user and
stakeholder definition stages or you
perhaps trying to reduce manufacturing
costs improve reliability and so forth
we take all kinds of projects and given
the overall system requirements we take
you through the tool pot tool box in a
systematic way where the customizability
and where the teaching staff comes in is
how you apply the tools to your
particular challenge because each of our
projects that we see that the students
bring they're going to have a different
emphasis and application of the tools as
we march toward that ideal embodiment of
features cost in time to market okay
let's go to the next life so
mentioned we are a project-based course
so that means students in the class
whether you're on campus or remote will
be working on a project throughout two
quarters so we are a two-quarter course
7317 a and 3 17 b we start in the second
week of january this year you can see
that's January 9th we hit the ground
running and we run through the first
week of june so it's two quarters long
you have a project so we're going to
open up the floor to questions in a few
moments so one of the questions out
there wait a minute where the projects
come from there are two two
opportunities here we have projects that
are sponsored by companies for our
on-campus and local SCPD students so if
you fall into one of those categories
you have an opportunity at the beginning
of class to select a project that will
be offered from anywhere from four to
six companies that make their
presentations what they want you to work
on if you are remote SCPD based student
you and the fact I think this is where
the real power is you have the
opportunity to work on a internal
project at your company we in being a
very industry focused and project-based
course we realize there are challenges
with non-disclosure and you know company
secrecy and so forth we have no problem
handling those kind of constraints in
terms of using an internal project to
teach the principles in the class but
the ideal case is that you do work on an
internal project it's something that
you're responsible for anyway and you
can use our class then to both get
further education and credit as well as
you know improving an internal design
for the company we run over to quarters
there's just a couple major milestones
during the course at the end of the
first quarter you will produce a report
there are no exams in this class so the
finals anytime you see final up there
it's related to a final report and a
final presentation we do have plenty of
homework it's I guess a hallmark of
Stanford engineering project based
courses that are they're not traditional
sense
studying for quizzes and exams typically
you are doing a lot of rolling up your
sleeves and actually working on a
project submitting progress reports in
terms of homeworks and then showing your
actual development efforts through your
presentation essentially your chance to
market your product ideas so that
happens twice in terms of finals so
final presentations and reports at the
end of the first quarter in the second
quarter one other thing I'll mention
about this particular class I mentioned
that there is a fair amount of
customization and guidance from the
teaching team in terms of how you apply
this toolbox to your particular project
development challenge one other hallmark
of this class is that almost weekly you
are making presentations to the eat of
the class or the teaching team you're
almost immediately applying the
principles that you've learned in the
previous lectures to your project and
you're receiving feedback if you happen
to be associated with on campus you're
receiving feedback from the on-campus
students as well as the teaching team
and we're essentially we're doing the
customized coaching of how you apply
these methods to your particular problem
how those tools and methods work on your
particular project what you should be
doing next what are your opportunities
perhaps that you know this particular
kind of project may offer now another
question that comes up is well what kind
of projects are suitable and we run the
whole range these days the kind of
projects that we see whether we won
distinction I make is hardware like the
a5 icon airplane that you saw up at the
beginning of the presentation that thing
makes a noise if you drop it but we also
deal with products that if you drop it
it doesn't make a noise think of
something like Netflix which is
presumably a service that most of you
are familiar with of course if you
dropped a BB D it might make a noise but
the value proposition or the central
product of that company is a service so
from a product or a system development
perspective the
analysis approach to understanding
stakeholders the business models the
potential failure modes of both your
business model and the service itself or
the product itself all of those
underlying principles are the same we're
really the devil is in the details in
terms of how you apply particular
methods to solving certain problems so
we address a wide range of product
system and business process development
type challenges in our course so I think
with that I'm going to wrap up the
formal discussion of the class and I
think at this point we're going to open
it up to questions and discussions thank
you for participating in our
presentation today and sharing your
research with our audience we're going
to respond to audience questions and
while we collect your questions from the
queue I like to take a few moments to
share information about the two courses
that will be offering this winter
quarter taught by professors Dave beach
and curb biter a little bit information
here the Stanford center for
professional development serves as a
bridge between Stanford University and
industry offering academic and
professional education courses and
programs to meet the career long
education needs of engineers scientists
technology professionals managers and
executives our center is in part of the
Silicon Valley extending Stanford
education for over 50 years and based on
customer feedback having access to
Stanford level education is critical to
maintaining a competitive position in
the marketplace the Stanford center for
professional development offers
approximately 200 graduate courses each
year that can be taken online for
academic credit without having to be
formally admitted to a degree program we
offer bundled courses or graduate
certificates comprised of three to five
courses in a focused guided curriculum
of study which offers not only Stanford
University graduate credit but also an
in-depth subject specific knowledge we
also extend math
there's degrees to industry through our
honors cooperative program candidates
must apply like any other graduate
student and if admitted can pursue their
degree on a part-time basis over the
course of five years up to 18 units of
graduate credit earned under the non
degree option may later be applied
towards a masters degree we also offer
the option to audit courses allowing you
to update your knowledge without
homework exams or interaction with the
staff and the enrollment period for
winter quarter is currently open and
will remain active until one state
January fourth if you're interested in
enrolling in any other graduate course
is offered through the Stanford center
for professional development you must do
so online through our website at SCPD
dot stanford.edu tuition is determined
by SCPD come company membership and non
membership if you are unsure about
whether your company has a membership
with a Stanford center for a
professional development or would like
to learn about the benefits available to
member companies I encourage you to
contact us I would also like to
highlight and upcoming webinar we have
scheduled for january 18th but on the
topic of positive intelligence this live
webinar will talk about maximizing
potential and performance in the area of
project management at this point I'd
like to conduct the final poll in our
webinar please indicate your level of
interest in the graduate courses
reference today while you're entering
your response I'd like to ask our
speakers some of the questions that
received from our audience today
professor is one of the questions that
came up was a what process do you use to
validate design we use qualitative
marketing principles doing field
research initially and then I would
advocate but not included of course is
prototype building and distribution for
market testing yeah but I was just
extending what Dave said prototype
building is always a part of what we do
whether we're prototyping the problem or
the actual solution in our course we
start moving you much farther along in
terms of business model validation the
reality of anything academic or on con
class is unless you have a particular
unique opportunity it's really a
incubator or kind of a laboratory type
experiment where we we certainly
encourage validation in the sense of
prototyping and testing it before users
and actually trying to you know
prototype the manufacturing processes
but the real meat of course and this is
where you have the opportunity working
in industry is that you've you've taken
the chances or the opportunities in an
environment where you can fail and you
know failure is often thought of as a
bad thing but in kind of project
development work we do we look at it as
a huge learning opportunity so
validation push mainly through
prototyping and just getting it out in
front of users but you know it's the
devil's in the details curve I just have
to add co2 cell for that wonderful
exposition of products I think I teach a
course called design and manufacturing
twice a year it has 90 students the
first thing we do is a student's march
into the classroom as we stand in circus
foul posture and we yell at the top of
our lungs altogether I failed because
it's my belief that until you failed you
can't possibly have to go forward that's
awesome all right let's take a look at
our next question this person says my
product is very simple but has
ramifications that need much thought and
work is there a limit on house
well the product can be well from the
perspective of 317 I would say no and in
fact in terms of learning and you know
complexity of a project being hindrance
this could actually be a positive it's
amazing the amount of information and
analysis perspectives you can have or
investigate just in a simple single
component mechanical device things like
you know a one-piece can opener can have
a user interface they have a
manufacturing system that goes behind
making it there's a business model
behind that there are various
stakeholders that you have to consider
whether it's the end user or the
traditional stakeholder we might think
about but what about folks down in
purchasing what about management of the
company that's concerned about the
possibility of that project the folks
that you might contract manufacturer
this device helps too so what I would
say if you have a simple and that's a
very loaded word in itself if you have a
simple product i would encourage
certainly looking at that is even a
greater opportunity purpose perhaps so
if you compared it to more complex
products this is something that it's
easier to tackle in terms of the whole
design the final assignment and good
products bad products is a study not a
physical prototype which looks at the
product of the team's choice through the
lens of function and economics human fit
craftsmanship needs and emotions
elegance and sophistication cultural
values and global constraints that's a
wonderful opportunity to explore with
three teammates two or three teammates
through the lens of human values how
your product might do and to contemplate
refining it in appropriate ways alright
here's here's an interesting question
can I product be a good product at just
the wrong time perhaps the public is not
quite ready for an advanced concept due
to public perception or other external
factors or would you consider that just
to be a bad product a good product is
absolutely time dependent it's very hard
to get guest speakers to come into good
products bad product and talk about
their failures but every once in a while
we succeed and there's a local company
in santa cruz have developed an
underwater
amer product which one design awards all
over the world which was clearly
technical superior to anything else but
it came 18 months late to the market and
it came over budget so the price was too
high and by that time everybody who
wanted a product in that category had
already bought something from a
competitor that product because it was
late almost bankrupt the company
involved yep and this echoing what they
said I one of the tag lines on my slide
was by the way you know something
happened on the way to the market and
that certainly the interpretation of
market timing it can you know it's clear
to you know I think there are clear
examples of get it arriving to market
too late that is competition has already
gotten their customers potential
customers have moved on because they
found other ways to satisfy those
functions and so of course but that
that's interesting that that releasing a
product too late it's you know contend
that failure in that scenario can come
from several different perspectives you
know one of the common examples that we
talked about quite a bit in product
development is like the ipod and you
know the that it's an interesting i
think saying that it Apple who was a
company not particularly you know that
wasn't their product depth consumer
products personal device obviously they
did personal computers but there was
just the right I guess technology arcs
of miniaturization music becoming
digitized first through CDs many years
ago and then through the internet so an
even the internet itself in terms of
allowing the whether legal or not rapid
and easy sharing some music all of those
arcs coming together in an enabling a
business model that up until that point
had really not taken off the Apple was
certainly not the first PDA sorry the
additional musics our mp3 player to hit
the market but they were the ones that
really
learned how to make money at doing that
now of course there's a lot of other
things that went into success of that
product in terms of their marketing
their product design in terms of the fit
form and function and so forth but again
that was certainly an example of timing
in terms of the right technology and
societal changes and other kind of
supporting infrastructure arcs all
reaching maturity at the right point
just one other Apple example they came
out with a Newton it's probably giving
away my Aegis was the early 90s and it
was much much awaited by certainly that
the technological or the computer-based
press and ultimately I guess you could
say a failed as a product I don't know I
guess you can measure that several
different ways it certainly had a very
devoted following but it was home if you
will if you want to throw Newton and the
palms computing into the same market
with their PDA that really was
successful and you could we could you
know spend quite a bit of time
discussing why or why not one product
was successful and another Pleasant that
certainly timings in terms of not just
consumer readiness and perhaps you know
leading consumer to use a new products
but also just technology and can you do
what you need to do with the existing
technologies a couple of our examples
are fun I think my 1950 GMC pickup truck
is probably not the perfect product for
freeways in California today it was
magnificent for its intended purpose
which was farm use what sixty years ago
and the icon a5 would not exist today
unless the FAA had defined a light-sport
aircraft category enabling pilot
training to be greatly shortened
enabling performance of small planes to
go way up so they became much more
attractive so the question that came up
is our are your courses only related to
hardware products are also toured
software products the products bad
products has traditionally focused
mostly on hardware that's where the
readings are and most of our guest
speakers have launched hardware
companies or have a lot of
responsibility and major companies like
General Motors
or on the other hand we are opened
project work being done in the in the
arena of services or environments and we
have one of the most interesting
projects ever done was a redesign of the
Safeway store so students went out with
our video cameras and they watched
people shopping and then they
interviewed people and the whole process
of what makes a good interview is an
interesting one my favorite single topic
on the subject is michael berry who is a
founder of jump associates and that's
their business as need finding he says
the right way to do an interview is
create a script do your homework really
understand who you're going to talk to
and what questions would be reasonable
and then you launch with your script and
as soon as the customer goes in some
other direction especially if it doesn't
make sense or seems to you to be wrong
that's what you want to jump on that's a
flag that there's gold right there and
then what you want to do is just speak
enough to keep the balloon in the error
it's the metaphor is you to tap the
balloon it floats for a long time slowly
comes back down try and have the people
you're interviewing doing almost all of
the talking and if you can get them to
the point where they're telling a story
of some kind or other now you've learned
something valuable which could be used
to redesign a product this group of
students redesigned the safeway by
laying out the store in a completely
different way changing the signage and
then they did an animated cad adventure
so that those of them they felt in the
audience could have that shopping
experience in the redefine Safeway and
they dressed up as if they were business
consultants so they came into the
classroom in pinstripe suits and believe
me I don't see my students spread it
that way normally and they did a
wonderful job of presenting to us the
clients the executives of safeway the
redesigned store yet so the I mentioned
in my part of the presentation that
things that don't make a noise when you
drop them is actually become a larger
part of our product population or
project population over the years we
traditionally that is 317 we the
curriculum comes traditionally from the
plant floor so we got our roots
motorola six sigma and designed for
assembly and that oh you know wow if we
could just address some of these issues
in the design phase some of these
manufacturing issues we're seeing boy
wouldn't it be nice if you could fix it
during design if you a heck of a lot
cheaper and we get this product out on
time and so forth but over the years and
I don't think this is necessarily
something that's just specific to the
Bay Area I mean obviously we have
computer industry is strong here
software you know web 20 web 30 and so
forth those are all kinds of things that
are not physical hardware based that is
on the software side of things and so we
do see a high percentage of those kinds
of products but the other way to look at
it is almost except for the what I'm
thinking is an increasingly rare
occurrence that you have a simple say
mechanical only object almost any
concerted consumer product these days
are going to have a strong software
firmware and service-oriented components
to the overall product function and
whether we are dealing with you know
manufacturing that widget or delivering
that user experience that's heavily
supported by software we need to be able
to address design challenges you know
business model challenges production
challenges and so forth no matter what
so we in terms of our courses deal with
you know business processes service
services as a business site processes as
well as hardware all right let's go on
to the next question for good products
bad products do you discuss the design
process not just a project based as in
the a and b-class or is it more of a
servile survey of white certain products
failed or succeeded due to the design
process good products bad products has
two essential components one is
inspirational so design process but also
business models and also personal life
styles get discussed by a variety of
guest speakers perhaps the most
interesting person on the agenda for
this year is coming from us from
what is it called Silver Lake equities
fund and they have just put together a
new alternative energy component and
George Soros is a major player there and
his partner in that named Adam grocer
will be talking to us about global
constraints so you get a notion about
design process and also business process
over and over again from a variety of
entrepreneurs most of whom are not
famous enough that you've read their
books are read about them in the wall
street journal but they're just one
level below so they're very very
successful practitioners very successful
entrepreneurs whom you wouldn't get to
meet in any other way the second way in
which design process is represented in
good products bad products is through
the syllabus so the first assignment is
design field research to learn something
about consumers using a product or an
environment or a service and that's
based on bunny ones lecture typically
the next thing to do is go out with
video camera and sound equipment and
observe the use of products by those
people implement your research project
with the nut with the eye towards
discovery and there they there what
you're trying to do is come up with
something you hadn't thought about
before they're the magic is something
unexpected happens when the next
assignment is turned that discovery into
some kind of a story which would inspire
or lead the design of a product or a
service or an environment and then
finally in team format you put together
final presentations and they want to do
two things they want to have high
production values I care about lights
costumes quality of sound quality of
images quality video and anything else
you may do if you're a remote student
that will be encoded by making a video
of the presentation and sending it to us
if you're an SCBT student who lives
close enough to campus that you can
participate on campus then you could do
things like bring food add sent to the
classroom and so forth so the whole
notion of attention to aesthetics is
very important there the second prong in
that assignment the second thing is
highly regarded if you teach us
something new at electorally that you
break new ground and insight into one of
the atoms topics I think all of that is
correctly characterized as design
process it's different from how so plop
your Institute of Design
design process complimentary and
therefore very powerful alright our next
question is I don't have a background in
mechanical engineering is an engineering
background necessary for this for these
courses okay for 317 engineering degree
is not required we do require a
bachelor's degree and that takes a
typical of most of our stanford graduate
courses so math you know all the linear
linear algebra and you know differential
equations all that stuff well it's
important in product development it's
just in 317 and i think probably in 314
it's not something that you'll be doing
on your homeworks there is some math in
our class but it's math with the purpose
that is we show you what problem are
trying to solve and it's actually you
know we understand immediately why
you're doing it why are we here and so
forth see just to give you kind of a
technical challenge or difficulty
braixen the main tool we use in our
class that have anything to do with math
and technical side of things would be
excel so whereas you could be using pad
and FF EA to validate or evaluate
specific I'm context not something
that's required one other thing I would
put on there in terms of putting
together a project based team ideally
you have all facets of the business
perspective you know just a development
system perspective represented and of
course that some of that's going to be
engineering but business side the you
know industrial design side of things
product management side of things
manufacturing and so forth so we
emphasize a team-based environment in
for our remote sgp d student said
something we can talk about it like how
do i put together a team but we really
need all perspectives when we're talking
about a product consistent development
the wonderful thing about a university
is it has many departments in many
fields and it's the interaction among
those professionals and activities that
makes the university very very exciting
i teach SCPD principally to get the
perspective of people in
industry you bring a tremendous amount
to the course because you're not located
at Stanford in general and that's
fabulous and if you don't happen to have
a degree in engineering assuming you
have a bachelor's and some things do it
you're absolutely welcome the other
element of diversity and good products
bad products is we attract quite a few
business students and we are now
authorized as a general engineering
requirement for undergraduates so we get
a whole flock of philosophy majors and
VTS majors and the discussion is so much
richer because of that diversity I would
actually be very disappointed if
everybody in the course their degree in
engineering alright um so the next
question is how our issues of
intellectual property address in these
courses okay that is perhaps a
particular challenge for any project
based class that a company especially
when a company is sponsoring a project
so to answers or they're related there's
two parts if you are a external SCPD
student who is working on an internal
company project you're the IP is and
remains slowly of the possession of the
company that the student works for okay
if you are working in the other context
other project context that is we have I
mentioned up to six companies may coming
be coming in and saying hey we have a
problem for you to work on these
companies like you know Cisco the Oracle
just to give you some examples they come
and present a problem that they would
like a team of students to work on in
this particular case so we call this a
project affiliate or a sponsored project
the IP is treated in one of two ways
depending on what's developed if it is
IP based on an existing IP that the
company already owns that remains with
the company if it's something completely
new so that student team comes up with
something that is you know a new feature
or a new widget then the IP is jointly
well Stanford owns it the company has a
non exclusive access to use it however
they want to use it but Stanford if it
was a case of a patentable idea Stanford
would pursue that patent this is in is
to repeat this is in the case where it's
a company a project sponsored by company
and it's completely new IP not based on
any existing IP owned by the company
they just also reiterate if you are
working on a project from your company
all IP remains with the company there's
no Stanford involvement at all there is
normally not an IP concern in good
products bad products we're not
generating products we're generating
insights into existing products if your
site is nervous about sharing some
project you're working on you are free
to select some other target for your
final report it may be very helpful to
you to work on whatever you're doing
professionally as a way of getting more
efficiency from your hours invested but
we are going to present publicly
whatever it is you present and
consequently you may want to choose
something from somewhere else all right
I have a somewhat of a lengthy question
here but this is an interesting one
based on your experience what insights
can you share with us on how small to
medium scale companies could best
protect their new product ideas and
minimize the risk that larger companies
will engage an idea theft art after
gaining access to the prototypes
developed for the prospective investors
one option is to fully secure all
patents and registrations first but that
opens up the serious risks we just
discussed today that of waiting too long
and releasing the product to wait into
the market that's a really tough
question I'm so glad you asked it
because it gives me a chance to think
and not just give an automatic answer of
some kind I think there's always a
balance between sharing information and
protecting information and I think that
details of where that balance lies have
something to do with the size of the
company something to do with a product
domain something to do with the intended
market and something to do with the
culture surrounding the organization
that's developing the product in general
my own belief is
that intellectual property is absolutely
critical to a startup company they are
after all small and relatively
defenseless they can afford fewer legal
fees and the bigger companies can and so
it's it's especially sensitive I think
what I observe in the world is at
certain companies I'll pick on apple
sense Curtis brought Apple up have
better security Donna Pentagon does say
really as a matter of corporate culture
pay attention intellectual property I
who take field trips all over the world
looking at manufacturing sites cannot
get into apples model shop they just
want to let me in on the other hand I
have students who have lunch projects
John Stanfield what everyone needs is a
small electric essentially a buckboard
which contends to enter the market at
you know under ten thousand dollars and
be a utility vehicle and his view is the
more visibility it gets the more
partners he attracts the more technology
he can attract and the better off he is
so I think that's a deeply insightful
question and you really have to look at
the details of the organization to
answer yeah and I would echo that I hate
to give an answer that says you know it
depends but in this case I think it
really does when we talk about just on
the logistical project-based side of
things if something is so sensitive that
probably it's just better to treat that
outside of the realm of 317 and perhaps
314 as well but in terms of how we treat
that in a system development process one
aspect of we cover in the class I
mentioned there's a lot of things that
can go wrong on the way to market and
this could certainly be how you treat
this issue could certainly be one of
them but risk analysis and how you frame
the risk and your response to that is
going to be part of any system
development that has an exposure to this
kind of risk so that's something there
is no magic Silver Bullet answer it was
something that we would certainly
concern ourselves with during the
business development process since it's
such a hard question to answer that it
depends answer is an easy one and
probably not all that helpful though was
my offering and Curtis followed my lead
I'd like to point out a couple other
things so there are other ways in which
a product could succeed and one of them
is quality of implementation
and so manufacturing and manufacturing
quality are at least as important not to
say intellectual property isn't
important but they're also very very
important and I believe after many years
of being a professor who was brought up
in a family where any time you bragged
about yourself you were being
uncivilized I think I finally learned
that marketing is really important and
it's self-promotion death is not an
option it's a responsibility all right
let's look at the next one a question
asks do you cover or teach the
regulatory aspects of product design and
how that particular project will be
regulated for regulatory quality
professionals that has to be a question
I'm going to guess that space theatre
and medical products are in the
aerospace ended I somewhere and we do
not teach regulatory design principles
in good products bad products there are
other courses of Stanford right that
address them quite well and they tend to
be medical design products yep I mean
and that's a reality in our side of
design as well again it would be similar
to the last question we don't
specifically teach the principles of
regulatory design but its regulatory
agencies are a very important
stakeholder in dealing with them in our
business development product development
process is you know part and parcel of
those regulated industries so it's not
the elephant in the living room it's the
elephant in the living room that we can
actually see and we do have to deal with
yes all righty um can individual
students enroll without a team how do
individual students work on projects
that's especially interesting for good
products bad products you may be alone
at your site and we encourage that and
what we will do is we will have a
logistics system in place to help you
find two other team members and they
also may be alone at their sites and
that's the reality of design today phone
calls are picked at a time of day when
both in Asia and in New York the person
is still awake and possibly functional
so communication with modern digital
tools is a very effective way for teams
to operate in good products bad products
and we will help assemble those teams
yet we have a similar response to Dave
yes we
support remote students and what we call
remote Singleton's I would say if you
are a single person not in the Bay Area
so not able to attend on campus and you
would love to take 3 17 and you have an
internal project well you could have two
cases an internal project to work on or
you would love to join an on-campus
seeing even though you're a 3,000 miles
away we can handle these on a
case-by-case basis you would just have
to work with me and or the TAS to do
that we're at state manager we would
either team you up with other remotes or
actually I find a way where we can
include you on an on-campus project
we've done that before we've also
supported single remote students working
on their own projects that is possible
what we would want to handle that on a
case-by-case basis there is I mentioned
there's no finals in terms of exams
there's no quizzes but there is plenty
of project-based work to do and working
alone can be doable but we just want to
make sure that the student is clear
roughly requirements alright that wraps
up the question and answer session for
today today's presentation has been
recorded and we will be sending out the
link to all registrants we welcome
inquiries and follow up and we'll stay
online to answer any questions remaining
in the queue you may also contact our
student services at SCPD dash customer
service at stanford edu or you can call
student services directly as 650 725 30
16 once again thank you everyone for
attending today and we hope to see you
in the winter quarter thank you very
much